[Applaus]
vorletzten Samstag ist etwas
Unglaubliches passiert es sind Züge
ausgefallen und ja ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich das erklären soll es war nicht
die Schuld der Deutschen Bahn
bei Herne und in Berlin wurden Kabel
durchgeknipst und dann ging erstmal
nichts mehr über Stunden Überstunden
seitdem
seitdem diskutiert Deutschland über
kritische Infrastruktur wie sicher ist
die bei uns geht so tatsächlich haben
wir das Thema jahrelang völlig verpennt
weil ich meine für sind die Deutschen
uns lieben eh alle wer sollte uns
schaden wollen aber wie genau haben die
Saboteure das gemacht bei der Bahn woher
hatten die das Know-how wie naiv man
bisher war zeigt sich daran dass die
Anleitung zur Bahn Sabotage praktisch im
Internet stand denn die Bahn hatte das
rückfallkonzept für den Ausfall des
zugfunks öffentlich ins Netz gestellt
endlich mal guter Kundenservice bei der
Bahn
muss man dann auch mal loben können sie
aber alles nachlesen in der neuesten
Ausgabe der DB debil
ich meine klar das gehört zur Wahrheit
34.000 km Bahngleise die kannst du gar
nicht rund um die Uhr schützen logisch
und wichtig ist ja auch nur dass man den
Schaden schnell repariert und dass man
auch seinen Fehlern lernt die von
Unbekannten zerstörten Kabel noch am
Wochenende von der Bahn gepflegt
zumindest
der Riegel mit Kabelbinder gesichert
wahrscheinlich könnte den jeder
12-jährige mit einer Nagelschere öffnen
ja bei Cluedo würde ich jetzt sagen ich
möchte lösen es war der zwölfjährige
Kevin mit Mamas Nagelschere am Bahndamm
ja wer hätte das gedacht Sabotage ist
kinderleicht jedenfalls bei uns in
Deutschland ja
tatsächlich tatsächlich stellen auch die
Betreiber von Windparks Krankenhäusern
oder kleineren Verkehrsbetrieben immer
wieder sensible Informationen ins Netz
und die Doofheit der Bahn ist ja gerade
zu filmreif Tom Cruise dreht schon in
Deutschland
okay ich bin drin ich
Versuche nee nee nee warte die haben das
alles komplett online gestellt ehrlich
alles welches Kabel wohin läuft was man
damit Laden liegt alles schwach sein so
blöd ist doch keiner anscheinend doch
man muss nur googeln
das heißt Feierabend
ja Feierabend
schön possible the stupid Germans
ich weiß nicht
von Fuß
jetzt wird man schon von Scientologen
beleidigt so weit ist es
tatsache ist allerdings Deutschland muss
seine Infrastruktur besser schützen aber
genau dafür haben wir ja Innenministerin
Nancy fäser und die arbeitet in einem
Gesetz
dass die dass die Betreiber von
Infrastruktur verpflichten würde sich
besser selber zu schützen denn 80
Prozent der Infrastruktur befinden sich
in private Hand
cybersicherheit kostet halt Geld was
übrigens nichts kostet sind sichere
Passwörter also sicherer als die hier 1
2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 [ __ ] 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
das sind die fünf häufigsten Passwörter
einer halben Million E-Mail-Konten toll
toll politisch korrekt wäre übrigens das
Passwort eins zwei drei vier fünf
einvernehmlicher Geschlechtsverkehr aber
das nur am Rande das nur am Rande so
einige Probleme wurden jetzt immerhin
mal angegangen zum Beispiel die
Überdachung von stromumspannwerken um
sie vor Drohnen zu schützen das ist
überfällig denn ein bundesweiter
Blackout ist zwar sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber auch sehr gefährlich was das für
Deutschland bedeuten würde hat sich der
Bundestag schon 2010 von Risikoanalysten
berechnen lassen Ergebnis spätestens am
Ende der ersten Woche wäre eine
Katastrophe zu erwarten mit dem Tod sehr
vieler Menschen
ja und wenn sie mal richtig scheiße
drauf kommen wollen lesen Sie das Ganze
Gutachten die beschreiben da wirklich im
Detail wie dann erst Ampeln ausfallen
also keine Angst nicht die Regierung
richtige Ampeln dann Internet Mobilfunk
es käme sehr wahrscheinlich schreiben
die zu Plünderung ja ähm kein
Leitungswasser kein Leitungswasser und
kein Benzin weil tanken nicht mehr geht
wenn Sie all das kalt lässt meine Damen
und Herren der Thermomix läuft dann auch
nicht mehr so jetzt bricht Panik aus und
das ist es ist eben keine Panikmacher es
ist Vorbereitung notwendige Vorbereitung
auf den Worst Case haben Sie sich einmal
ausgemalt was ein tagelanger Blackout
bedeuten würde denken Sie doch nur an
die abertausenden Menschen die in
Fahrstühlen eingeschlossen werden um
Gottes Willen ein Albtraum
mit gauland im Fahrstuhl stecken bleiben
ich nehme nur noch die Treppe so und
noch ein unlustiges Detail aus der
Blackout Studie ohne Benzin könnte sich
auch unsere Polizei nach wenigen Tagen
nur noch auf Pferden fortbewegen
wirklich gut dann müsste man natürlich
sämtliche Fernsehserien umschreiben ich
sag nur Polizei Ruf 110 und Notruf
haferkante ja es können Sie dann zwar
gar nicht mehr gucken wegen Blackout
aber irgendwas ist ja immer
gibt es denn auch Fortschritte beim
Katastrophenschutz die deutsche
Bevölkerung soll künftig vor regionalen
Katastrophen und Notfällen per SMS
gewarnt werden können das hat der
Bundesrat beschlossen demnach soll das
Verfahren namens cell broadcast bis Ende
2022 eingeführt werden in anderen
europäischen Ländern ist es schon viele
Jahre lang im Einsatz
ja gut ich meine wir können uns jetzt
nicht mit zivilisierten Ländern wie
Holland vergleichen
nur weil die Angeber das hinkriegen
vielleicht vielleicht müssen wir unsere
Ansprüche auch einfach mal
runterschrauben wir brauchen ein
Warnsystem im Rahmen deutscher
Möglichkeiten mal angenommen es brennt
ein Umspannwerk in der Nähe von
Wernigerode sowas muss ja nicht die
Polizei beobachten das können doch auch
die machen die sowieso immer alles
beobachten du meine Güte da brennt ein
Umspannwerk sofort melden Sie das bei
der zuständigen Stelle nehme ich in der
Stammkneipe von ihrem Mann was machst du
denn hier du glaubst es nicht
so spannwerk brennt alles klar
und der Hermann startet dann die analoge
Meldekette für Katastrophen nacheinander
erstrahlen die waren vorher an der
Wasserkuppe dem kleinen Feldberg und dem
Kahlen Asten und das sieht man dann im
Bundesamt für Katastrophenschutz in Bonn
guck mal an in Wernigerode brennt das
Umspannwerk
es geht auch es geht auch
übrigens übrigens
weiß ich alle gerade so auf Russland
fokussieren unsere Geheimdienste waren
diese Woche also ganz aktuell auch vor
Cyberangriffen aus China ja aus China ja
und sie waren vielleicht zu Recht sowohl
im deutschen 4G als auch im 5g-netz
steckt jede Menge Technik vom
chinesischen Staatskonzern Huawei das
Innenministerium prüft schon seit Juli
ob man die Netzbetreiber zwingen kann
diese Technik nachträglich wieder zu
entfernen aber die Industrie meint das
wäre ihn zu teuer das stimmt ja immer
klar für die deutsche Wirtschaft wäre es
ein Albtraum wenn wir uns jetzt auch
noch mit China verkrachen im Gegenteil
höchste Zeit sich einzuschleimen meint
till Reiners live vom großen
Volkskongress in Peking
die heute-show verneigt sich vor dem
mächtigsten Mann der Welt chising Ping
she sei unsere Fackel in der Nacht
Deutschland liebt dich
ja komm jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
überraschend aber wir müssen jetzt auch
mal eine realistische aus dem Politik
machen wir haben ja schon Russlands
Krieg mit Sanktionen bestraft das ist
eine gute Sache aber unsere Wirtschaft
schafft immer nur eine Diktatur zu
sanktionieren deswegen wäre china-wagen
na klar große Denker der Bundesregierung
wussten das schon lange die chinesische
Politik chinesische Konzepte china ist
ein Wettbewerber chinesischen
chinesischer chinesischen China die
Chinesen Chinesisch Estland
Island ist vielleicht auch bald China
aber ganz ruhig erstmal ist Taiwan dran
wir bemühen uns um eine friedliche
Wiedervereinigung mit Taiwan dennoch
werden wir uns niemals dazu verpflichten
auf die Anwendung von Gewalt zu
verzichten
ja also wenn sich Taiwan nicht selber
China anschließt muss man es überfallen
da sind nämlich hier die Hände gebunden
und trotzdem wird in Deutschland wieder
gemeckert wegen Uiguren und so ich kann
es nicht mehr hören Leute Menschenrecht
haben jetzt mal Pause wenn es falsch war
sieht man gut den abhängig zu machen wie
kann es denn richtig sein Abhängigkeiten
gegenüber sieht Sinn bring Dich zu
thematisieren liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde Reinhard kommst Du bitte zum
Schluss
schlechte Laune wenn man so abhängig ist
von China wie wir 10% des deutschen
Außenhandels nur ein Beispiel 80 Prozent
aller Bauteile für unsere
Photovoltaik-Anlagen werden in China
produziert ja heißt es dann aber warum
haben wir das bei so einer wichtigen
Technologie zugelassen die Lieferketten
blablabla diese ewigen Nörgler die
bekommen von mir jetzt die Achtung
hätte hätte Fahrradkette herzlichen
Glückwunsch euch sehe gerade die ist
Made in China oh schade dann nicht
positiv rangehen und sagen wir wollen
von lernen der weiß noch wie man
Parteitage stramm organisiert inklusive
synchron-tee einschenken finden Sie mal
so viel Virtuosität beim Fassbieranstich
auf dem Oktoberfest von China lernen
heißt siegen lernen oder Scholz hat es
längst verstanden gegen alle Widerstände
von 6 Ministerien setzt er jetzt wohl
durch Teile des Hamburger Hafens gehen
doch an den chinesischen staatskonzernen
cosco von wegen China spioniert unsere
Infrastruktur aus china kauft unsere
Infrastruktur sheasingping ist einfach
ein Diktator zum Liebhaben und kann man
jemand böse sein der so eine eigene
coole App für Journalisten hat 100
Fragen mindestens 80 muss man wissen um
zu bestehen Kostprobe was verlangt
Präsident Chi von politischen Kadern
wissen oder Loyalität zur parte
Loyalität ist richtig
das wusste ich ich fordere Deutschland
muss Olaf Scholz endlich mal genauso
abholten wie hieß ab sofort nicht im
heute show AppStore die Scholz App
beispielfrage wenn Olaf Scholz ein
Ertrinkenden sieht was macht er dann
Antwort A abwarten bis ich das Problem
von alleine löst oder Antwort B er
bewirft ihn mit Geld damit er mit einem
doppelwurms aus dem Wasser kommt oder
Antwort C ein echter Olaf Scholz
beantwortet keine Fragen zu einfach oder
ja C ist richtig wer ist gewusst hat
gewinnt die Autobiografie von Olaf
Scholz Erinnerung an meine Treffen mit
der Warburg Bank ganz ehrlich ich habe
es verschlungen
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze voll
ja los lasst ein Abo da